l'histoire de la confrérie mais il y a
c'est toute une bande de copains qui se
réunissait le dimanche matin au café
donc et surtout avec Michel miso et
notre Grand Commandeur qui a eu l'idée
justement de relancer la poule et le
pâté dedans et ça a mis quand même
quelques années parceque
en juin 2016 cinq copains voilà qu'on a
remis au goût du jour le célèbre pâté et
la poule de Houdan on en est fier on a
une pensée pour Michel qui nous a quitté
donc c'est lui le père fondateur de
cette confrère
à la paroisse au bar comme les copains
autour d'un zinc je pense comme beaucoup
de millions de Français voilà le
dimanche matin nous sommes rencontrés
cinq compas cinq fondateurs il faut bien
commencer donc on a commencé à 5 après
on a fait des chapitres qui est notre
grande messe annuelle et tous les ans on
a double des nouveaux des nouveaux
chevaliers gentodam entre 20 et 25 donc
Véronique une des premières Jeanne de la
confrérie
donc nous avons travaillé avec la
coutellerie de Thiais un couteau
connecté donc là l'étui que couteau à
l'intérieur et l'astuce c'est que vous
prenez votre couteau avec une puce
intégrée
et vous passez votre téléphone qui va
passer par là vous passez votre
téléphone et vous arrivez tout de suite
sur le site de la confrérie
vous avez toutes les informations de la
confrérie le futur concours
le futur au chapitre en 2023
[Musique]